-Our first guest tonight is
an Oscar-nominated, Emmy-winning
actor you know from movies like
"The Imitation Game,"
"The Hobbit," and
the "Avengers" franchise,
as well as
the series "Sherlock."
He stars in
"The Power of the Dog,"
which is in
select theaters today
and on Netflix December 1st.
Let's take a look.
-Now, gentlemen, look, see --
that's what you with the cloth.
-Oh!
-Right.
-It's really just for
wine drips.
-Oh, you got that, boys?
Only for the drips.
[ Laughter ]
Now get us some food.
-Please welcome to the show
Benedict Cumberbatch.
Hello, Benedict.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hi, Seth. How are you?
-Now, Benedict, I know you
to be a lovely person,
and that is very much not who
you are playing in this film.
-You should see me on
a Monday morning.
No, I mean, it was a bit of a
reach, to say the least.
And, I mean, you know,
it's a strange one.
You get a call from Jane Campion
and you just say, you know,
"What? When? Where?
I'm in."
And then you find out
what it is and go, "Why me?"
She had faith.
She knew there was
something about this character,
something that made him
truly vulnerable
underneath the hard exterior of
sort of toxic masculinity
that she thought
I could bring to it.
And she had every faith that I'd
get the kind of --
the heart and the kismet down.
And I have a few experiences
I -- She was amazing.
She was amazing
in rehearsals, as well,
production, and ever since.
And she said,
"Look, if there's anything
you're feeling insecure about,
we're here to help you
as production."
Please let us know."
And I went, "Uh...okay.
Banjo playing,
being an ass[bleep]
whittling, whistling.
I mean, just this list of
things this guy has
lived, breathed, and mastered
over 40-odd years
of his life on this ranch
in 1925 Montana.
So they took me to dude camp,
and I learned to do everything I
did in the film, pretty much.
-I mean, not only do you get to
work with Jane Campion,
you get to shoot in New Zealand.
That must have added to the
many pleasures of this project.
-Oh, I mean, you know,
it's her kingdom,
but, my God,
it's such a welcoming place.
Everyone there is sort of
hard-wired to be hospitable.
And that landscape is another
character in the film
and just a gift for an actor,
especially one playing
a character who's so much
about the outside
and bringing the outside in.
He's a man who
never takes his clothes off.
He never washes.
He's incredibly buttoned up
and contained
and dirtified by his work in
a very honest way.
And, you know, the landscape
is also his refuge.
It's the one place where he can
be private and be true to the
sort of the secret
that he's hiding
and find this sort of moment
to express that
and connect with that.
And, at the same time,
it's what he masters --
the weather, the animals, the
men that help him run the ranch.
And to be in a place like that,
which is truly still
some of the most, I think,
spectacular wilderness
on the planet, was just
such a gift for this movie.
-So, I heard that you went
a whole week without showering.
Was this a choice that you made
for your character
or did Jane ask this of you?
-It's such a thing,
this sort of people not washing.
But, yeah, this was for
character work,
I would say, first and foremost.
And it was a request, and my
family hasn't yet arrived
to the country,
so that was helpful.
However, you know,
there was a cleaner
who came in
once or twice a week.
And then Jane went,
"Oh, this is great.
So, we're going to meet some
friends for sushi.
And I'm like, "Oh, no.
I'm like a biohazard sign."
I'm walking 5 feet
in front of me, you know.
People wanting selfies are
gonna, "Can I have a -- Ugh!"
And just run in
the opposite direction,
which is not
a bad thing sometimes.
But, you know,
in rehearsal and just to feel --
This guy didn't wash
for like months.
So it's pretty tame.
It's big in our
modern-day environment
of cleanliness
and one or two showers --
open the debate -- a day.
But, you know, yeah,
it's quite something to go there
even just for a week.
It's very peculiar.
-So, I heard Jesse Plemons,
who plays your brother,
the incredible actor --
that one of the things
Jane asked was
for you guys to, as actors,
learn each others' smell.
She asked you to waltz together,
to take an
afternoon nap together.
Now, I have to ask,
does it take a director of
Jane Campion's level
for you to say, "Okay."
-[ Chuckles ]
Uh...yeah, kind of.
It's not a request I get much
on the Marvel set.
But, look,
I'd happily take a nap with
Jesse Plemons on any job.
-Yeah, yeah.
-He's a sweetheart and an
extraordinarily gifted actor,
one of the best, if not the
best, of our generation.
I have so much
admiration for him.
And, yeah, you know,
there we are as brothers
suddenly just thrown together
for a brief moment of
trying to create this story.
And these guys,
odd as it seems to us now,
shared the same bedroom.
Not the same bed.
We didn't nap in the same bed.
But, you know,
what is it to sort of lie
beside one another
in those sort of --
everything that
sleep is about,
to be something
that's sort of shared
in such an intimate space.
And, you know,
I've grown up with the guy.
I've knocked about with him.
We've fought.
Everything that brothers do
over their lifetime.
And I was just meeting this
very cool dude
that I was full of
admiration for, off an airplane.
And, you know, to be thrown
together in such a peculiar way
was actually
really, really helpful.
It just broke that down
and made it something real
and connected.
And, yeah, all preciousness
just evaporated.
It was great.
-It so funny to me.
And, again,
it speaks to your great range
as an actor to work on
a project like this
where it's very much, like,
the authenticity
of learning another
actor's smell
versus you mentioned
a Marvel movie,
where you show up,
and it's like,
"Now pretend that over there
is a monster."
-I know.
"There's the person you smell.
It's a Ping-Pong ball."
Yeah, I know.
But, you know, I think it still
requires the same kind of
level of interrogation
and authenticity.
You're just using
your imagination a lot more.
Not least because,
you know, you can't afford
to fix it on a post when you're
doing a film like Jane's.
And, you know,
the real-world environment
is a gift in that sense for
"The Power of the Dog."
And, also, the sort of childish
game play and just freedom
of imagination for doing the
sort of Marvel work is --
It's a different muscle,
but it's equally as interesting
and challenging for me.
I love both. I really do.
-You seem like someone that
would be great to
collaborate on a film set,
and, yet, I heard a story
that early in your acting days,
you were in a school play
as a young man.
You were playing Joseph
and you thought the actor
who was playing Mary was
taking too long
with her line
and you shoved her offstage.
[ Laughter ]
True story?
-Yeah.
-Yeah. Okay.
Yeah, true story.
And this voice came across an
outdoor swimming pool
in Hampstead, near where I live,
only last year,
going, "Benedict, Benedict,
I was the Mary you
pushed off the stage
when we were kids."
You know,
this fully grown adult.
And I said, "I don't know where
to put myself right now.
I'm so, so sorry."
And she went, "Oh, no.
It's great.
I dine out on the story."
So...
-Yeah, I guess that's true.
I mean, if you're not going
to make it as an actor yourself,
you might as well
get shoved by someone
who's been
incredibly successful.
-No, I would not --
Yeah, I wouldn't advocate
that as a way into a career.
-So, then you -- Obviously,
you go on to drama school.
What kind of student
were you then?
-Um...mixed.
You know, I had great respect
for a lot of the process,
a lot of the classes,
and then, at other times,
I think I hadn't
got being the sort of
student who liked to
sort of muck about
and make his friends laugh
at the back of the class
out of my system.
And, you know,
there were moments
of great integrity and stuff
that I learned,
great pearls of wisdom
and just shards of things
that just I exorcise
all the time in my work,
and then other moments
where I was going,
"This is just -- You know,
I need to sort of do something
to not get bored and just
entertain people
at the back of the room."
So, I would say a mixed bag.
But I'm very proud of my school.
I'm president of LAMDA now.
And, you know,
I think there's lots of things
I'm grateful for
and the privilege of
my upbringing and my life,
but one of the things
I notice most is,
at the beginning of
an actor's career,
every single advantage counts.
And so we're trying really hard
to make that school
as accessible
and as inclusive as possible.
So that's a thing
I'm really proud of
being part of and being back
in that environment to do.
But, yeah, at the time, yeah,
I could be a pain in the ass.
-Very nice, very adult of you to
be able to admit that now.
You also have a show
coming out on Amazon Prime
called
"The Electrical Life of --"
am I saying this right? --
"Louis Wain"?
-Yes, you are saying it right.
You are saying it right.
I'm super-proud of this film.
The director and re-writer,
I should say --
It was Simon Stephenson
originally,
but it's Will Sharpe.
He's an extraordinary talent.
And, rather like Jane,
he just has a master of
every aspect of filmmaking,
from the ratio of the screen to
the texture of the clothing to,
I mean, you know,
even going up to the first
five minutes in the recording
of his brother's score --
it's a very talented family --
and saying, "This is what
the character's feeling
at the moment that
you're playing this theme."
And it was just --
I fell in love with Louis.
He's a very quiet hero
in a loud Victorian world.
And he suffered a great deal,
finding it difficult to be
in this world.
He was diagnosed
in his life with schizophrenia,
though he's not here now,
obviously, to ask or observe.
So, out of respect, we're less
prescriptive in our take on him.
But, you know, he struggled.
And it's really a film
about love,
the love he had for his wife,
beautifully played
by Claire Foy,
sustaining him throughout
his life and his career.
And -- Oh, gosh.
I don't know.
I mean, there are just
some characters
that don't leave you alone.
I loved Phil Burbank,
perversely,
'cause he's a troubled dude,
but, Louis Wain --
There's just -- Yeah, I've got
a real soft spot for him.
I think he's
a very special human being
and a story worth telling.
-Well, I can't wait to see that.
And congratulations again
on the film.
It really is -- It is a film.
We were talking briefly
before the show.
And I know it sounds
a little pretentious,
but it is really
a piece of cinema
and it's incredibly engaging and
it's a wonderful story.
But congratulations.
-Thanks so much, Seth.
Thank you.
-Benedict Cumberbatch,
everybody.
"The Power of the Dog"
is in select theaters today,
on Netflix December 1st.